[Musique]
ce samedi 13 novembre s'est déroulé la
journée départementale des personnes
âgées au jardin de l'État ils étaient
plus de 10000 cette année à avoir fait
le déplacement pour leur rendez-vous
annuel l'occasion pour les gramounes
d'échanger de se retrouver et de
s'informer sur les dispositifs mis en
place par le Conseil
départemental c'est très important déjà
pour les personnes âgées parce que le
département œuvre déjà contre
l'isolement c'est important que les
personnes âgées puissent se rencontrer
parce que nous savons très bien que
pratiquement 80 % des personnes âgées
vivent à domicile et qui évidemment les
enfants qui vont travailler tous les
jours ne pe ne peuvent pas rester avec
eux donc c'est un point de rencontre
pour eux rompre l'isolement et puis se
rendre compte aussi de ce qui se passe
dans l'évolution donc de la situation
des personnes âgées dans le cadre de ce
rendez-vous annuel en V village
agricoolle des ateliers de sport de
santé de bien-être ont été mis à la
disposition du public des stands
d'information sur les nombreux
dispositifs d'aide aux personnes âgées
mises en place par le département ainsi
que les actions partenariales étaient
également ouverts aux
participants sur le site du jardin
d'État ce jour nous avons donc mis des
stands dédiés pour informer le maximum
d'informations récupérer aussi bah des
doléances voilà de personnes qui n'ont
pas eu forcément leur réponse la réponse
attendue puisqueel quelque fois on a des
délais qui dépassent un petit peu voilà
l'attente de la personne et également
l'ensemble des partenaires qui uvrent au
quotidien auprès des personnes âgées
donc on leur a proposé d'être sur sur le
sur le site du jardin de l'État pour
faire connaître l'ensemble des droits et
pour les personnes âgées on leur donne
un petit fasicule qui permet
de donner les 10 signes
avantcoureur et après on les oriente de
se renseigner près du iatrie de façon à
se faire détecter par un médecin car
nous nous sommes là que pour orienter
nous ne pouvons pas détecter la maladie
aujourd'hui on est présent la C base
parce que Ben la cécité touche tout le
monde c'est les personnes âgé de temps
en plus avec le diabète et plein de
maladies d à l'âge donc la DMLA et nous
sommes là pour présenter le dispositif
que le Conseil départemental à à
Saint-Pierre c'est un dispositif unique
on va dire à la Réunion et même dans la
France métropolitaine c'est un service
accessible pour les personnes déficient
visuelles malvoyante et non voyante
malgré une journée de deuil et de vive
émotion suite aux attentats de Paris les
gramounes ont tout de même profité de
leur journée un moment convivial où les
générations se rassemblent pour échanger
partager et rompre l'isolement ben
formidable il y a plus de monde que
l'année passée déjà et puis bon ben les
convivial quand on voit tout ce me t les
personnes âgées se rassem
et puis bon ben là on rencontre de la
famille des amis on rencontre beaucoup
de gens des gens qu'on a pas vu pendant
un an l'année passée on n pas vu ces
gens là cette année on les revoit cette
journée tous les
VI réunion
n pas
général je suis ici pour en profiter
cette journée et c'est important pour
moi pour pour ma maman et puis
mon fils qui qui est handicapé encore
une fois cette année le Conseil
départemental a su mettre à l'honneur
les personnes âgées en leur dédiant
cette journée l'occasion pour la
collectivité de mettre l'accent sur
l'importance de nos gramoun tant pour
leur connaissance que pour la générosité
qu'ils ont à nous
[Musique]
offrir
I